Speaker 1: So we have unfortunately fallen so
far in terms of the discourse that is considered.
I don't want to say typical or acceptable. Maybe
typical is a good word, not normal and acceptable,
but unfortunately what has become typical in the
modern sort of discourse of the American right
wing that over the last week, we had multiple
calls to violence not only from former President
Donald Trump, but his former national security
adviser, Michael Flynn. And it barely got any
attention. It barely received any reporting.
I mentioned it Monday when we talked about the
whacked Trump rally over the weekend. It was
one of 10 or so clips that I played for you,
but it really has not gotten the attention
that it should get, given that we know
that their followers are not only capable of
violence, but they're willing to do violence,
as January 6th showed us, among other instances
of political violence. So as a reminder,
what are we talking about? Here's
Donald Trump over the weekend,
when he called on his supporters to
quote Lay down their very lives to fight
Marxism and critical race theory.
Speaker 2: Remember this?
Speaker 3: Anything getting critical race theory
out of our schools is not just a matter of values.
It's also a matter of national survival.
We have no choice. The fate of any nation
ultimately depends upon the willingness of its
citizens to lay down, and they must do this lay
down their very lives to defend their country.
If we allow the Marxists and communists and
socialists to teach our children to hate America,
there will be no one left to defend our flag or
to protect our great country or its freedom.
Speaker 1: Lay down our very lives to fight
Marxism, socialism, communism and people against
people who want to teach critical race theory.
This is not only unhinged, it's not only based
on things that aren't even really taking place
in this country, but it's targeted at a group
of people that are willing to get violent.
Michael Flynn spoke to a Q and on conference
a few days ago Michael Flynn, one of Donald
Trump's former national security advisers, and
he was talking about charging the machine gun
nest again. More violent imagery and language.
Speaker 2: Can you to charge the Machine Gun Nest?
Maybe I'm just asking you to dig a little bit
deeper there. Or hold this side of the line.
Or form up because we're going to counter
attack over here and that counter attack is
we're going to go after school boards. And now and
then those those people, those people that then
fight them back. We got this problem in Iowa
right now. And these are Republicans. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So listen, you can argue that part
of the rise of Trump was the media gave him
too much attention very early in the Republican
primary. That's a fair criticism that can be
made of corporate media. We're now seeing
the opposite problem, which is now that
he and they have tens of millions of followers who
would still vote for them if he ran again today.
He and his associates, like Michael Flynn, are
using violent imagery and alluding to calls for
violence. And it's not getting coverage anymore.
And of course, the right the ideal situation would
have been the opposite. They should have ignored
and modestly ridiculed him in the beginning,
which might have prevented a lot of what
ultimately happened. But now that this I mean,
you know, we it's sort of a neo fascist movement
now that it is an obvious and real danger to the
United States. They should be doing their
job and shining a light on what it is that
they are doing. And unfortunately, you know,
the people that are already in this circle,
they're going to suck it up and absorb it no
matter where it airs. That's the reality. So
it is a bit of a no win situation. And at the
end of the day, the people that did the inciting
really need to be held accountable. And
that includes up to and including Trump.
And it's not looking particularly
like that's going to happen.